sa liste n'ont jamais rien fait je vais
vous dire sans l'argent que les
socialistes ont mis de côté quand il
était au gouvernement
votre réforme ne serait même pas
financés au premier sentiment merci
messieurs jean jacques mirassou merci
madame la présidente et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues la nation
réaffirme solennellement le choix de la
retraite par répartition au coeur du
pacte social qui unit les générations
voilà le principe je serais presque
tenté de dire le postulat qu'affiche le
texte dans cet article avec un lyrisme
qui ne vous a pas échappé mais qui
malheureusement est contredit à mesure
qu au fur et à mesure que l'on rentre
dans le texte c'est interdit de me
rappeler notre système de répartition
date de 1945 à l'issue du travail du
conseil national de la résistance et il
est fondé sur un pacte
intergénérationnel au terme duquel les
actifs paient pour la génération
précédente
or cela est également dit les effets
conjugués du choc démographique de la
crise économique de logements
considérable de l'espérance de vie fait
que actuellement le ratio entre
cotisants et retraités est beaucoup plus
pénalisant qu'il ya quelques années
j'espère d'ailleurs au passage que
personne ne songerait à déplorer
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie de
nos concitoyens
il en résulte que que là aussi tout le
monde est d'accord
une réforme est impérativement
nécessaire nous sommes effectivement je
l'évoqué tout à l'heure face
un problème sociétal qui est difficile à
régler mais qui dès l'instant où
revendique une société abouti a le
devoir de résoudre sans pour autant
remettre en cause le principe qui
prévalait en 1945
et c'est bien parce que ce problème est
complexe qu'ils justifient ou qu'il
aurait justifié pour le résoudre
du temps de la concertation du dialogue
et surtout ce un impératif de justice
une méthode que vous avez choisi de
mépriser et d'ailleurs vous avancez dans
ce projet avec le soutien
j'ai failli dire la complicité du groupe
ump restant sourd à la mobilisation est
donc nous trouvons dans une discussion
qui a tout à l'heure a eu toutes ses
conséquences et tout son prolongement
il est encore temps du reste mais sa
collègue d'écouter notre avertissement
de marquer une pause et d'imposer des
solutions en ce qui vous concerne
qui malheureusement à l'heure actuelle
sont présentés comme un est un simple
mais qui en réalité sont simplistes et
en tout cas inefficace et injuste
les cotisations repose on l'a dit
essentiellement sur les salaires et est
donc impératif d'élargir l'assiette en
s'interdisant pas de trouver d'autres
ressources telles que celle qui vient
d'indiquer à l'instant david assouline
le constat pour le moment il est simple
et il est clair pour l'ensemble des
français
ce sont toujours les mêmes à qui on
demande de consentir les efforts 85% de
l'effort pour les salariés le travail et
15% seulement pour l'hérault les hauts
revenus
avec au passage une prise une
pénalisation des femmes des jeunes des
retraités des handicapés des manières
plus large et des plus démunis à qui
vous demandez de serrer la ceinture
alors que scandaleusement 2ème temps et
bien le bouclier fiscal permet à
certains 9
certains voiliers de rentrer des sommes
de 300 400 mille euros ce qui est
parfaitement indécent nous pensons ce
qui nous concerne qu'il est possible
d'agir afin de sauver notre retraite par
répartition dans un système qui
constitue une application fondamentale
du principe de solidarité qui est chère
aux traits public système a fait ses
preuves a fait les preuves de cet
avantage
et dans ce temps de crise financière a
contrario et singulièrement à l'étranger
la capitalisation a fait la
démonstration de ses dangers et de son
inefficacité
mais sous couvert de la recherche d'un
équilibre le gouvernement monsieur le
ministre privilégier une approche
strictement comptable dans laquelle les
salariés se considérait comme une
variable d'ajustement
il ya donc de votre part un véritable
dévoiement du mode de répartition
puisque si répartition il ya elle se
contente de s'y limiter aux efforts qui
tombe sur les mêmes je veux parler des
salariés la répartition la vraie c'est
l'expression forte et juste de notre
système de sécurité et il est bon de
favoriser le principe d'autorité d'un
monde que nous vivons dans l'égoïsme
c'est seville dans les esprits et
parfois dans les corps il ya long de
votre part monsieur le ministre
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
une forme d'escroquerie intellectuelle a
revendiqué ce principe de répétition que
vous nier tout au long du texte et qui
fait qu'en fin de compte cet article et
de fait disqualifier
merci la parole comme ce very débat
merci madame la présidente messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
dans son programme le conseil national
de la résistance avait prévu une
retraite permettant aux vieux
travailleurs de finir dignement leurs
jours aujourd'hui je n'ai pas peur de
dire que votre texte revient sur cet
acquis majeur de notre pacte républicain
ce texte est une régression qui va à
l'encontre de ce que les français
attendent et ils attendaient un vrai
débat et de la concertation
ils voulaient une réforme juste il
voulait que la vérité soit respectée il
souhaitait enfin que la réforme soit
efficace cette loi est tout l inverse
elle est brutale injuste inégalitaire et
inefficaces comme l'a démontré avec
talent notre camarade et collègue
christiane demontès
et je partage bien sûr l'inquiétude et
la colère de ces millions de français
qui se sont exprimés lors des
manifestations et donc vous refuser
d'entendre les revendications légitimes
pour revenir à cet article nous ne
pouvons bien entendu qu'être d'accord
avec les principes fondateurs qui sont
rappelés toutefois on ne peut se
contenter de les reprendre seulement
pour la forme
ces principes nous engage alors que les
dispositions de ce texte de loi vont à
l'encontre même de ce qu'il représente
on n'a pas le droit de bafouer comme le
fait cette loi ainsi l'alinéa 4 de
l'article réaffirme que la retraite par
répartition est au coeur du pacte social
qui unit les générations d'hier ceux ci
c'est faire semblant d'oublier que ce
projet de loi va rendre le droit à la
retraite moins accessible dire ceci est
d'autant plus malvenue
quand il est fait référence au droit à
une pension et en un traitement
équitable
quelle que soit l'activité ou le régime
de cotisation mais quelle équité
y aurait-il alors que l'on allonge la
durée de cotisation at on pleure sans
tenir compte de l'âge d'entrée dans la
vie active
j'entends d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre que vous nous apportiez
quelques éclaircissements à la suite des
déclarations faites par le premier
ministre dimanche dernier dans une
émission télévisée
trouvez-vous juste que quelqu'un qui ait
commencé à travailler à 18 ans soit
obligé de cotiser 44 ans pour ma part je
considère qu affirmer ceci c'est faire
insulte aux travailleurs qui ont des
carrières longues et je suis curieux de
savoir comment on peut affirmer comme
cet effet que ce texte va permettre à
ceux qui ont une carrière longue de
toucher une retraite plus élevée
je prendrai un autre exemple comment
oser parler d'équité
quand le texte confort sciemment
pénibilité et invalidité
comment oser parler d'équité enfin quand
on voit le sort réservé aux femmes dans
ce texte
ce n'est pas d'équité qu'il s'agit mais
d'injustice injustice et même cynisme
comme le montrent les dispositions
concernant les seniors les chômeurs et
que penser du dernier anne il est là qui
fait référence au maintien d'un niveau
de vie satisfaisant de transparence de
solidarité et de pérennité financière de
quelle solidarité s'agit-il
quand les salariés vont devoir supporter
comme ça a été dit avant moi
85 % - d'une réforme alors que les
revenus du capital sont encore une fois
protégé pérennité financière mais qui
pourrait croire que ce texte là y
contribuera envie de le fonds de réserve
des retraites en rogne sur les droits
des femmes
on se livre à des opérations comptables
en 3 / en chômage assurance vieillesse
on méconnaît la pénibilité et on rend la
situation de millions de seniors encore
plus difficile mais on ne résout rien
la meilleure preuve que ce texte n'a de
réformes que le nom que vous les donnez
monsieur le ministre
car en 2008 18 il faudra encore et
revenir
non décidément les français n'ont pas
été et ne sont pas respectées puisque à
point il avoir escamoté le débat le
gouvernement dont vous-même estime
doctement qu'ils se trompent le
parlement enfin n'est pas respectée on
lui pose encore une fois la procédure
d'urgence comme s'il fallait empêcher à
tout prix qu'il puisse légiférer
serainement cet article m'a aidé en
artifices un cache misère bien mais
c'est moins bien mais ce pour masquer
l'énormité de la régression sociale
qu'impose ce texte dans tous les cas
nous avons fait des propositions
responsables pour une réforme des
retraites juste équitable et efficace
elles vous ont été rappelés par notre
président de groupe jean pierre bel
nous vous les rappelleront tout au long
de ce débat et nous attendrons de vous
que vous les prenez en compte je vous
remercie
la parole est à madame nicole bonnefoy
socialiste merci madame la présidente
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues notre dispositif de retraite
est l'aboutissement d'un long processus
historique et politique qui a conduit à
la création d'un système par répartition
base de notre modèle social s'appuyant
sur la solidarité entre les générations
aujourd'hui face à des mutations socio
économique mais aussi à cause de
certaines dispositions que vous avez
prises et qui ont mécaniquement
entraîner une diminution du niveau des
pensions notre système de retraite est
remis en question par ce que vous
appelez une réforme mais qui n'en est
pas une
en effet monsieur le ministre une
réforme c'est faire des choix qui règle
un problème et qui apporte un mieux aux
personnes qu'elle conserve ici rien de
tel votre projet ne règle rien pour lé
équilibres financiers du système des
retraites et va aggraver la vie
quotidienne des salariés et des futurs
retraités
depuis que vous avez présenté votre
projet de loi monsieur le ministre vous
n'avez de cesse de laisser croire qu'il
s'agit là d'une fatalité et qu'il n'est
pas possible de faire autrement que de
rallonger la durée du temps de travail
parce que l'homme vit plus longtemps
mais pourquoi vit-il plus longtemps
parce qu'il a deux ses mains sur des
décennies améliorer son outil de travail
parce qu'il a par son intelligence son
savoir fait progresser la science
autant d'avancées qui sont l'oeuvre
humaine et qui doivent servir l'homme il
ne s'agit donc pas d'une fatalité mais
d'un progrès humain qu'il nous
appartient de mesurer et de restituer de
redistribuer à l'homme qui en est à
l'origine
et ce de façon juste et durable
mais quelle société voulons-nous une
société où il faut travailler travailler
travailler toujours plus pour gagner
quoi au bout le droit de partir à la
retraite à 67 69 ou 70 ans fatiguée usée
physiquement moralement ou les deux
et d'avoir passé sa vie à travailler ou
à rechercher du travail il y a un temps
pour tout un temps pour étudier un temps
pour travailler tant pour se cultiver
pour les loisirs pour sa famille et un
temps pour soi en maintenant l'âge de
départ de la retraite à 60 ans nous
permettons à ceux qui veulent partir de
le faire parce qu'il y a une vie après
le travail et nous redistribuons aussi
d'une certaine façon le travail quand on
sait que deux tiers des actifs de 55 à
65 ans n'ont actuellement pas d'emploi
et que dans le même temps le taux de
chômage avoisine les 10% et que les 18
25 ans n'ont jamais été dans une
situation aussi précaire
je déplore que cette prétendue réforme
soit à l'image de la société actuelle
qui renient l'humain au profit
d'intérêts économiques ne servant qu'une
poignée d'individus quand tant d'autres
subissent je déplore monsieur le
ministre la brutalité de vos mesures qui
ne vise qu'à répondre à la pression
conjuguée des marchés financiers et des
agences de notation qui exigent une
réduction des budgets publics et sociaux
dans tous les pays européens
les citoyens attendent de nous autre
chose
ils attendent que nous construisions un
système où s'articulent aspirations
individuelles et effort collectif
un système de retraite découlant d'un
vrai choix de société et non d'un choix
financiers merci la parole est à
monsieur clos de dôme et l1 cialiste un
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues cet art il que premier à
je ne vais pas revenir sur le premier
paragraphe qui dit la nation réaffirme
solennellement le choix de la retraite
par répartition au coeur du pacte social
qui me l'immigration je n'ai parlé dans
ma mon intervention précédente et je
vais pas y revenir
ce qui est sûr c'est que on fait comme
toute la loi le contraire puisqu'on a
faibli
le régime par répartition je voudrais
m'arrêter un instant sur ce qui est dit
dans la troisième phrase les assurés
comme le dit le ministre son collègue
les assurés doivent pouvoir bénéficier
d'un traitement équitable regarde la
retraite
quelle que soit leur activité
professionnelle passée et le ou les
régimes lente il relève sur le ministre
je voudrais vous rappeler que j'espère
qu'il écoute je voudrais vous rappeler
monsieur le ministre comment de mars
exactement le 26 mars
je vous avais questionné lors des
séances du jeudi
c'était quatre jours après votre défaite
régional et le lendemain ou le prévenu
le président de la république avait dit
je ne passerai pas en force ont parlé de
votre inculture
alors monsieur le ministre je terminais
en vous disant la prise en compte des
critères humains devra l'emporter sur
l'utilisation abusive dans la calculette
il s'agit avant tout d'un choix de
société et non de simples ajustements
financiers
alors la question qui se pose mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre
faut-il une réforme ou pas et bien je
vous prépare
oui il faut une réforme mais cette
réforme nous devons l'aborder sans tabou
et en partant du principe que depuis
la société a changé moi je suis prêt à
tout entendre et mais c'est l'objectif
d'une vraie réforme là monsieur le
ministre je regrette c'est pas une
réforme ce sont des ajustements des
ajustements faits à partir d'un travail
avec la calculette à la main pour le
dossier des retraites il ya deux portes
d'entrée elles sont les éléments sont
autant important l'homme que l'on il y a
d'un côté l'équilibré des régimes
et je suis bien placé pour savoir ce que
signifie l'équilibré des régimes et l'
équilibre de l'ensemble des régimes
j'en sais quelque chose mais l'autre
aspect c'est le montant des pensions et
depuis le début moi j'entends parler de
calibre des régimes est pratiquement pas
de montant des pensions
il ya donc deux portes d'entrée elles
sont toutes les deux la même valeur mais
pour moi on doit avant tout aborder le
problème à partir en premier lieu du
montant des pensions et c'est ce qui est
contenu dans la phrase dans la troisième
phrase de ces tactiques premier à que je
viens de lire
or or toute votre démonstration et
toutes vos affirmations parte tout du
dollar de d'un seul critère au départ le
critère majeur c'est l'équilibré des
régimes
et au diable le montant des pensions
c'est ça qui est grave et je continue à
considérer que vous abordez cette ce
projet et cette réforme est sous un
mauvais angle voilà ce que je voulais
dire en commentant cet article premier à
je vous remercie bien la parole et à
monsieur jean desessard oui madame la
présidente je vais prendre la parole
pour commenter également cet article 1a
premier alinéa la nation réaffirme
solennellement le choix la retraite par
répartition au coeur du pacte social qui
unit les générations
je pense que nous pouvons être d'accord
deuxième alinéa tout retraité a droit à
une pension en rapport avec les revenus
qu'il a tirés son activité globalement
nous sommes d'accord sauf pour les
petits revenus
parce qu'il faut qu'ils soient augmentés
et c'est pas obligé de reproduire les
grandes retraite à ceux qui ont eu des
revenus déjà très important a dûment
octroyés et on pourrait quand même
limité
les retraites dorées mais enfin
globalement c'est le principe général
troisième point les assurés doivent
pouvoir bénéficier d'un traitement
équitable au regard de la retraite
quelle que soit leur activité
professionnelle passée et le ou les
régimes dont il relève
là c'est la notion de solidarité
nationale et ont fait appel à la
fiscalité
donc tout n'est pas basé simplement sur
les cotisations
mais déjà on fait appel à fiscalité
puisqu'on sait très bien que les
retraites c'est effectivement par
répartition mais souvent les gens se
trompent ils croient que c'est
entièrement redistributif ce n'est pas
entièrement redistributive il faut qu'il
y ait un effort qui soit fait pour
maintenir un minimum vieillesse pour
assurer à les personnes qui ont eu des
grandes périodes de chômage de précarité
un revenu ce n'est pas automatiquement
redistributif donc s'il ya une réforme à
faire c'est pour que ça soit davantage
que re distributive que ceux qui ont
souffert dans leur vie professionnelle
va ne subissent pas la double ou la
triple peine
et j'en viens au quatrième article le
système de retraite par répartition
poursuit les objectifs de maintien d'un
niveau de vie satisfaisant des retraités
de lisibilité de transparence d'équité
intergénérationnelle de solidarité intra
générationnelle et de pérennité
financière et là j'aurai un mot à dire
par rapport au débat que nous avons
j'ai été étonné monsieur le ministre que
vous ne vouliez pas de référendum
puisque vous êtes si sûr de vous et vous
pensez qu'il n'y a pas d'autre solution
puisque effectivement vous nous dites à
la gauche
mais comment vous allez financer parce
que effectivement on est quand même à
front renversé la droite ça les titille
de passer à un système à points ou à
système comptes notionnels un système de
capitalisation les centres is le disent
dans le dans des communiqués de presse
monsieur le rapporteur a dit qu'il est
pour un autre système est souvent dans
la commission on a entendu un délai
sénatrice et des sénateurs de droite
dire qu'il faut envisager un autre
système
donc vous n'êtes pas vraiment pour la
répartition vous n'êtes pas là
jure aujourd'hui mais ça vous titille de
passer à autre chose puisque tout ce qui
est collectif ce n'est pas votre culture
c'est la culture de la gauche et là
paradoxalement mais oui mais oui mais
oui battant assumer d'être de droite
assumé bon mais là les c'est vrai on à
fronts renversés
parce qu'effectivement on a l'impression
que la gauche elle n'est pas prête à
financer le système de répartition et
quand monsieur le ministre vous dit
comment vous allez faire
on lui dit qu'il faut élargir à la
fiscalité et pourquoi faut élargir à la
fiscalité
parce que on a réduit la masse salariale
pourquoi on a réduit la masse salariale
parce que l'argent va plus au salaire et
vos capital et bien évidemment tout ce
transfert
eh bien il fait que on assèche les bases
de cotisation c'est ça qui se passe et
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on est
obligé de faire appel à la fiscalité
également quand les patrons ils
délocalisent pour pouvoir faire des
bénéfices encore plus important c'est le
chômage et kaya de chômage ya plus de
cotisations et là encore on assèche la
masse salariale et on peut pas baser sur
les cotisations
on est obligé de baser sur la fiscalité
et voilà pourquoi vous dites monsieur le
ministre mais vous voulez vous voulez
faire payer par la fiscalité il ya plus
de tout ça on le sait que vous êtes
dépensiers bon d'accord mais ce n'est
pas simplement ça c'est que dans la
concurrence européenne on baisse
l'ensemble des impôts par peur de faire
partir les gens vers les entreprises
on baisse l'impôt sur les sociétés en
france en allemagne on s'aligne sur le
moins disant fiscal on s'aligne sur le
moins disant social
donc c'est toute une politique qu'il
faut revoir et lorsqu'on veut maintenir
le système de répartition qu'on
maintienne effectivement l'emploi qu'on
maintienne un une masse salariale
suffisante pour pouvoir payer autrement
bien sûr on est obligé de faire appel à
la fiscalité
merci mais la parole et à madame
marie-france beaufils du groupe crc spg
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chers collègues messieurs les
ministres chers collègues cet article
1er ra avec un contenu générique est
fondamentale en même temps aurait pu
permettre une bonne entrée en matière
dans le débat avec la procédure proposée
vous avez voulu empêcher ce débat en
profondeur sur ce système solidaire au
demeurant alors même que nous n'avions
pas encore commencé nos travaux en effet
on nous expliquait avec force entrevue
télévisée articles de presse conférence
radiophonique que le débat sénatorial ne
toucherait pas au coeur de la réforme
attendue bien sûr par les agences de
notation mais que des aménagements à la
marge était possible sur des questions
comme la place des femmes celles des
handicapés la question de la pénibilité
ou celle des polypensionnés je pense que
les femmes salariées auront sans doute
apprécié d'être considéré comme un
problème mineur de même sans doute que
quelques-uns de nos anciens mineurs
atteint d'asbestose à l'instar des
plombiers chauffagistes ayant manipulé
l'amiante au fil de leur vie
professionnelle ou tous ses salariés
dont le travail est devenu une véritable
souffrance sans que cela ne vous
interroge nous ne pouvons partager cette
manière de voir et de faire
nous ne pouvons pas partager vos
propositions non l'allongement de la vie
active
que ce soit par l'accroissement de la
durée de cotisation par recul de l'âge
du départ en retraite n'est pas
inéluctable
non le régime de retraite par
répartition n'est pas irrémédiablement
vouée à la faillite à plus ou moins
longue échéance
comme vous le promets en permanence non
il n'est pas utile de faire croire aux
jeunes générations que leur retraite ne
sera pas payé vous avez voulu
présentez vos mesures comme des mesures
de bon sens
mais cette présentation a fait long feu
les manifestants voulons dit les
français le confirme à plus de 70% et je
suis certain que mardi 12 octobre ils
vous le redire on encore clairement
regardons la réalité notre pays compte
plus de 25 millions de personnes en
situation d'activité activités il n'en a
jamais eu autant il est même probable
que l'évolution des moeurs et des
structures familiales et dans le
mouvement de féminisation de la
population active largement entamée dans
les années 60-70 se poursuivre
conduisant la quasi totalité des adultes
en âge de travailler en position
d'activité à l'exception de ceux
poursuivant des études et de ce que leur
état physique privera de la possibilité
de le faire
notre pays n'a jamais été aussi riche et
les gains de productivité sont tels
depuis plusieurs décennies que le
travail d'un seul salarié aujourd'hui
vaut celui de plusieurs il ya 20 30 ou
50 ans la france est d'ailleurs un des
pays où la productivité est la meilleure
en europe pour mesurer la richesse du
pays nous disposons d'un paramètres de
mesure le produit intérieur brut et la
valeur ajoutée
la france produit aujourd'hui 1000
milliards d'euros de valeur ajoutée
quand on sait que le déficit de
l'assurance vieillesse et de 5,5
milliards d'euros en mesures de suite
l'effort à accomplir et si tant est
qu'il existe un déficit structurel ne
convient-il pas de faire en sorte non
pas de rationner les dépenses de
l'assurance vieillesse mais de renforcer
les moyens d'accroître les recettes
nécessaires à la pérennisation du
système
nous avons sur cet article du site coûte
aux conditions d'ouverture du débat
procéder à l'inscription dans la
discussion des amendements proposant des
dispositions relatives au financement
des régimes de retraite
car de deux choses l'une ou bien on
assume notre attachement à la retraite
solidaire par répartition ou bien on
cherche à mettre une autre réponse en
place et c'est ce que vous proposez avec
nos propositions la retraite solide
art devient avec vos propositions
excusez-moi la retraite solidaire
deviendrait peau de chagrin
de fait pour la cnav la réforme
actuellement proposée ne réglera aucun
des problèmes posés du point de vue des
déficits
nous nous sommes pour plus de recettes
pour l'assurance vieillesse
nous sommes attachés à ce que les rate
les retraités de ressources leur
permettant de vivre décemment
c'est aussi une mesure de respect de
solidarité envers ceux qui ont produit
les richesses sur lesquels nous
construisons l'avenir de notre pays
rappelons que ce sont plus de 12
millions de nos compatriotes qui sont
concernés nos amendements vous propose
de financer le système par répartition
où les cotisations des 1 permettent de
financer la retraite de ceux qui ont
déjà payé celle de leurs aînés
mais de plus nos propositions en
supprimant les dépenses faites par
l'état pour exemple tu es certain de
cette contribution solidaire
contribuerait à réduire le déficit de
l'état
aussi j'espère que nous pourrons avoir
un vrai débat sur le système par
répartition et son financement afin de
pérenniser véritablement le système et
faire en sorte que le régime déclaratif
de la première ligne du 1a est
véritablement tout son sens merci la
parole est à monsieur martial bourquin à
mme la présidente
ce mini chers collègues nous sommes tous
d'accord sur le fait qu'il fallait une
réforme des retraites est sans aucun
doute
sans aucun doute j'ai entendu hier les
différentes interventions et les
interventions du ministre nous disant on
a osé la faire on est courageux
vous n'avez pas osé et
et nous vous demandons d'élever le
niveau du débat voilà un peu je je
résume à peine mais c'est un peu ça
alors hall au delà
au delà du fait que nous sommes d'accord
sur une réforme des retraites mais qu en
aucun cas nous sommes d'accord avec
cette réforme là c'est autre chose qu'on
prendrait bien chers collègues que il ya
une différence de forme et de fond deux
formes faut toujours respecter la
personne à qui vous porter la
contradiction
les élus qui sont ici à gauche n'ont pas
la même opinion que la vôtre il ne
demande pas à être réhaussé dans leurs
niveaux d'intervention il ne pas tarder
il ne partage pas du tout la façon où
vous aviez envisagé cette réforme et
c'est ça le faut pourquoi cela parce que
prendre un temple un ton condescendant
en dix ans excusez nous élever le niveau
c'est déjà pas bien respecté ses
contradicteurs la seconde change
la seconde chose on peut le dire ici on
n'a pas du tout les mêmes valeurs
concernant certains points
par exemple comment demander à des
personnes qui travaillent beaucoup très
difficilement en trois huit de doublage
dans des travaux pénibles de leur
demander comme ça vous allez cotisé deux
ans de plus et en même temps redonné un
chèque à madame bettencourt de 30
millions d'euros
ben oui mais c'est ça ce fait il faut le
dire un deux en même temps
en même temps de redonner des chèques
aux plus grands contribuables français
et de poursuivre et de poursuivre et de
poursuivre cette scandale qui est lequel
bouclier fiscal écoutez chers collègues
ce sont des questions de fond
pourquoi vous est inaudible pourquoi il
ya trois millions de personnes dans la
rue mais parce qu'ils ressentent ça
comme une profonde injustice c'est cette
crise financière terrible terrible que
tout le monde a connue rappelez vous
comment nous étions dans ses thèmes ici
que la gauche et à droite pour se
demander comment sortir de cette crise
ils ont le sentiment
ils ont le sentiment qu à la sortie de
crise ce n'est que qui paye les traders
ils sont tranquilles le bouclier fiscal
ea continue et en même temps on leur on
les met au chômage
écoutez écoutez chers collègues comme en
commandant un projet comme celui-ci on
n'a pas abordé un seul moment le fait
que 4 million deux cent mille personnes
sont inscrites au pôle emploi et on nous
dit pas s'ils cotisent est combien ça
ramènerait pour les retraites
pourquoi à aucun moment on ne dit que le
chômage de match le mas coûte très cher
à notre protection sociale et au retrait
à aucun moment peser pourquoi parce que
vous êtes habitué à ce chômage de masse
parce que il est organisé et presse et
et c'est une résignation effectivement
devant la situation économique et
sociale du pays
alors nous nous avons une autre
conception et si vous voulez bien on
élève le niveau
vous avez dit elle présente la
république il y a il y à quelques temps
lorsqu'on est en pleine crise les stock
options c'est fini les bonus c'est fini
les retraites chapeau c'est fini chiche
chiche mettons le aujourd'hui à l'ordre
du jour proposé une fiscalisation des
bonus proposés une fiscalisation des
retraites chapeaux là on les vôtres avec
vous et on aura cette union nationale
dont on parlait hier parce que c'est un
authentique scandale quand il y à plus
de 4 millions de chômeurs qu'à côté il y
ait cette opulence c'est pas possible
quand il ya cette pauvreté quand il ya
cette précarité
en même temps on demande toujours aux
mêmes de faire des sacrifices et
maintenant de cotiser deux années de
plus
voilà la situation telle qu'elle est et
vous n'êtes pas compris vous ne serez
pas compris
parce que celles et ceux qui souffrent
aujourd'hui centre comme une profonde
injustice ce que vous êtes en train de
préparer vous avez vous êtes en train de
faire payer très cher une crise que
celles et ceux qui subissent aujourd'hui
la subissent aujourd'hui noms ne sont en
rien dans sa genèse écoutez ce sont des
banquiers ce sont ceux qui ont mis en
place des systèmes concernant
l'immobilier qui ont mis en place cette
crise et aujourd'hui on en fait payer
pour avoir une bonne notation
le prix fort à celles et ceux qui
travaillent qui se lèvent tôt et qui
sont en train et qui font la richesse de
ce pays sous l'armure monsieur le
sénateur je suis je termine en disant
que je veux bien y rochelle niveau jeu
bien un vrai débat mais ont un débat sur
le fond et nous n'avons pas le débat sur
le fond on essaye de le mettre dans la
technique le font c'est qu'ils payent
c'est toujours les mêmes qui payent
l'apparent l'état monsieur jean louis
carrère
oui madame la présidente messieurs les
ministres pour rappeler quelques
éléments essentiels de qui devrait
guider notre débat s'agissant de la
réforme des retraites oui nous y sommes
favorables
et si on veut être tout à fait sérieux
on est même favorable est prêt à
travailler sur la base d'un certain
nombre de propositions revues que vous a
présenté tout à l'heure jean pierre bel
sur la répartition que vous évoquez avec
beaucoup de force
d'autres en d'autres temps vous aurez
viré partition répartition répartition
vous savez s'agissant de l'europe
l'europe l'europe l'europe voilà
non moi moi je vous dis pourquoi on va
pas vous faire un procès d'intention
imaginons un seul instant comme tom
d'accord sur cette volonté affichée
d'aller vers la pérennisation objectif
d'un système par répartition et des
travailleuses y apportant au contraire
des éléments de dialogue entre nous qui
devrait nous permettre de trouver une
solution
voir un contre
sur le financement de ces services de
retraite et n'acceptons pas justement de
ne pas avoir de financement qui juge met
à mal la volonté même d'aller vers un
système par répartition il y à une
incohérence grave
donc si vous nous dites on est prêt à
travailler sur la base du financement
dont service pas réparer une retraite
par répartition
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances qu'en vous donner des idées
sur la révision de la réforme fiscale
allons-y débattons mlomp les retraites
et leur financement à cette
problématique n'est pas de la manière
dont vous voulez nous imposer s'agissant
ensuite de votre méthode de négociation
je crois qu'elle est complètement
insupportable et même je veux regarder
des mots assez assez courtois
inacceptable dans une pratique
démocratique
vous avez vu le voc de tout à l'heure
c'est vrai vous avez gagné 181 à 142
grosso modo contact
sauf que je suis en train de vous dire
gentiment que les 140 qui ont voté pour
le process référent mer représente 70%
des choix de la population française en
ce moment est-ce qu'il est concevable de
les nier
non moi ce que je vous demande c'est
d'éviter de refaire un débat droite
droite on le voit ce débat vous feignez
de nous dire le sénat va apporter des
solutions
mais non mais cher mes chers collègues
vous n'allez pas apporter des solutions
parce que vous ne pouvez pas les
construire vous êtes de la même majorité
et vous voulez faire croire à l'opinion
publique que de cette majorité tout d'un
coup sortir et des solutions que vous
n'auriez pas trouvé préalablement si
vous voulez vraiment qu'on y aille avec
objectivité et volonté et aller vers ce
consensus que vous feignez d'appeler de
vaud veut discuter avec nous discutez
avec la gauche discuté avec les
organisations syndicales dont nous
pourrons porter un certain nombre de
revendications et là nous construirons
en vrai régime de retraite qui pourra
justifier d'un débat républicain dans
lequel nous aurons pris tout notre place
si tel n'est pas le cas
pardon de vous le dire nous nous y
opposerons parce que ce sera une
idéologie farouche de droite revancharde
contre une idéologie progressiste
la parole est à monsieur jean-pierre
café dernière orateurs inscrits gardien
attendait le débat n'est pas fini chers
collègues
merci madame la présidente
nous sommes sur cet article 1a qui a été
d'ailleurs ajouté au cours du débat à
l'assemblée nationale
et c'est un arctique qui moyennant
quelques amendements que nous avons
déposés que l'opposition a déposé
pourrait être acceptable car en fait ils
essayent de refonder en quelque sorte en
tout cas de réaffirmer le principe d'un
régime de retraite par répartition la
question chers collègues c'est quel
régime de retraite par répartition
je ne reviendrai pas sur tout ce qui a
été dit par un certain nombre de mes
collègues notamment martial bourquin sur
le caractère profondément injuste de ce
qui va sortir de cette réforme et
notamment nous y reviendrons bien
évidemment d'autres articles sur la
question des femmes que ce système que
cette réforme va considérablement
pénalisée
je ne reviendrai pas sur ce qui a été
dit sur le fait que cette réforme ne
pérennise pas le système sur le plan
financier
il suffit de regarder les tableaux qui
nous ont été donnés dans la commission
et qui figure à la page 42
on s'aperçoit que après retraite le
déficit cumulé en 2018 est toujours de
65 milliards d'euros et c'est la raison
pour laquelle d'ailleurs vous tombe vous
ponctionner vous
siphonner le fonds de réserve des
retraites
mais ce qu on a peu entendu depuis hier
depuis le début de ce débat et ce sur
quoi le gouvernement a beaucoup
argumenté c'est la comparaison avec nos
voisins européens
est ce que nous avons entendu ce dont
nous avons été matraqué pendant des mois
et des mois
c'est le caractère inéluctable de cette
réforme que d'ailleurs nos principaux
voisins européens avait adopté bien
avant nous alors regardons zee d'un peu
plus près et sur cette question monsieur
le ministre je suis obligé de vous dire
que vous avez menti
regardons ce qui se passe en allemagne
oui l'allemagne a décidé d'avoir la
retraite à taux plein à 67 ans mais en
quelle année monsieur le ministre
pas en 2023 en 2029 et ce malgré un taux
de natalité très inférieur à celui que
nous connaissons en france
regardons du côté du royaume uni même
chose
retraite à taux plein à 67 ans en quelle
année monsieur le ministre
en 2036 en 2036 les regardons l'espagne
c'est 2025
et il ya de fortes chances en fait que
cette réforme soit abandonné encore
faut-il rappeler que en allemagne et au
royaume uni pour avoir une retraite à
taux plein il suffit de 25 et de trentes
années de cotisations respectivement ce
qui fait que monsieur le ministre la
réforme que vous avez engagé et que vous
voulez faire absolument voter par le
parlement va aboutir à la situation
suivante c'est que en europe
le régime de retraite français tel qu'il
sortira de cette réforme sera le plus
défavorable aux salariés de toute
l'europe car vous avez cumulé
car vous cumulez non seulement les
mesures d'âge et nous y reviendrons
notamment à l'article 6 je vous promet
un beau débat sur cette question d'un
seul ministre mais non seulement vous
utilisez des mesures d'âge pour à peu
près la moitié des déficits mais en même
temps vous allonger les durées de
cotisation oui monsieur le ministre
cette réforme est injuste elle est
inique il ya n'aboutira à ce que en
europe
le salarié le moins favorisés du point
de vue de la retraite sera le salarié
français
voilà pour le début des discussions
d'hier soir dans l'hémicycle tout de
suite retour aux annonces d'eric woerth
ce matin le ministre du travail a fait
certaines annonces concernant les mères
de trois enfants et certains parents
d'handicapés
tout de suite on l'écouté monsieur le
président madame la présidente monsieur
le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
depuis que le gouvernement a commencé à
préparer cette réforme en avril dernier
il a maintenu une attitude constante
d'ouverture et de dialogue
le projet de loi initial quand tu es
déjà de nombreuses dispositions
directement issus de nos discussions
avec les partenaires sociaux
je pense au maintien du dispositif
carrières longues et à son extension à
tous les français qui ont commencé à
travailler à 17 ans je pense à
l'amélioration de la couverture retraite
des chômeurs non indemnisés je pense à
la prise en compte dans le calcul de la
retraite des indemnités versées pendant
les congés maternité des mamans le
dialogue s'est poursuivi avant et
pendant le passage du texte à
l'assemblée nationale avec les syndicats
avec les députés à l'assemblée nous
avons renforcé les mesures de prévention
et de compensation de la pénibilité ça a
été un moment très fort d'évolution du
texte le résultat de ce texte de ce
travail très étroit réalisé avec la
majorité parlementaire à l'assemblée
aboutit au fait que nous ayons tripler
le nombre de personnes pouvant
bénéficier d'une retraite à 60 ans à
taux plein grâce au dispositif de
retrait
pour pénibilité au sénat dès le passage
du texte devant la commission des
affaires sociales mme la présidente
le gouvernement a accepté plusieurs
propositions de votre rapporteur
dominique leclerc pour doubler le nombre
de travailleurs handicapés qui
bénéficient d'un départ à la retraite
anticipée et pour que la réforme ne
pénalise pas les chômeurs proches de la
retraite
enfin que les bénéficiaires des
pré-retraites pour amiante soit 1
clairement rassurée comme ç'avait été un
moment donné une discussion importante
vous l'aurez noté tous ces changements
poursuivre un seul et unique objectif
rang